hey guys this is Cameron with motion
science back with a cool tip for you for
After Effects based on effects this one
has to do with the videocopilot saber
effect I get asked all the time how I
created this smoky glow effect on the
triangle from the original motion
science logo that I created it plays on
a few of the videos here on YouTube or
the blog that you guys have probably
seen and it's this blue glowing triangle
and more importantly people ask how the
atmospheric smoke that moves across the
triangle was created so I want to show
you how I did that it's using a free
plug-in called saber from Video Copilot
and I'm sure most of you are big fans of
Andrew Kramer as am i you go to a site
download the free plug-in and install it
and you can follow along with this
tutorial
so in After Effects all I've got here is
just a simple black solid in my
composition I'm gonna go to effect Video
Copilot saber and boom there's our saber
with a full res here so this plug has a
lot of possibilities I've used it on
several projects I love this plug-in but
specifically I'm just going to talk to
you today about the distortion
parameters and under distortion glow
distortion is where I create the
atmosphere that you're gonna see in here
so in my motion science logo this was a
triangle which was simple mask I created
that this can follow I'm not gonna get
into that one but all we have to do is
just go into distortion amount and start
turning it up
to something fairly subtle well maybe in
there I'm actually gonna turn the rez
down to half so we couldn't see this
quicker but there's smoke which I
believe is what I use there's also fluid
and there's energy and these are just
using fractal noise textures to create
these effects
there's also distortion or multiply
I like multiply that it's a little more
subtle do a preview here actually let me
turn down this something much smaller so
you can see the smoke is moving upwards
set to multiply this is distortion which
it's a much much more harsh effect at
this point but it just depends on what
your taste is and what you're trying to
create so I'll go back to multiply I
really like that the wind speed
obviously adjusts how fast this moves
for what I did I changed the wind
direction I believe to 90 so now it just
goes left to right if I did negative 90
it'd go right to left something else
that's really cool with this plug-in is
the noise scale so currently it's set to
150 what's really cool is if you turn
this all the way down to one I like how
it has this kind of almost analog
digital interface effect going on it
just looks very low Phi and really cool
almost like maybe stranger things
something like that it's just it's just
a very cool look to it especially if I
go up to full res here that's
essentially it you can also play with
all these different noise complexities
you can turn it lower or higher the
scale the speed the if I go back
up to the scale here if we were at 150 I
go up much higher it's a much softer
kind of smoke effect going on here but
that's it's real simple like I said a
lot of people have asked how I created
this and there you go it's a simple free
plug-in called Sabre bye bye Video
Copilot
if you dive into the settings on any
plug-in typically if you really dive
into the settings you're gonna find a
lot more uses to the plug-in that then
what most people typically realize on
the surface what a plug-in is capable of
doing so if you liked the video please
like subscribe comment below and until
next time I'm Cameron and this is motion
science